ça me soit dernier la télévision canada
présenté un documentaire représenter un
documentaire sur sur dix ont une vraie
question du vivre ensemble
le procès 2.0 fine qui a été réalisé par
nadia zouaoui qui est juste là devant
moi bonjour nadia par jour fine que vous
avez fait nadière à l'époque de la
charte des valeurs de présenté par
bernard drainville à l'époque ministre
sous le gouvernement de pauline marois
parti québécois et quelques années plus
tard après un laps de gouvernement
libéral
un nouveau gouvernement québec la
coalition avenir québec présent une loi
sur la laïcité et il ya plein d'éléments
de votre sim d'il ya quelques années
qu'ils s'intègrent presse comme un
copier coller dans cette réalité-là
d'aujourd'hui ça fait tout drôle de ceux
de se dire qu'on revient qu'on replonge
dans le même film
qu'en pensez vous mais je ne m'attendais
pas au fait le film je les termine et il
ya deux ans mais ils pouvaient pas
sortir parce qu'il y avait vraiment un
procès au fait moi je les appelais le
procès par rapport au livre de kafka je
vais m'expliquer après mais il ya un
procès donc le personnage du film et est
allé en cours contre un joli lance
jamais donc le film ne pouvait pas
sortir et ça fait juste quelques mois
que dalila wada a gagné et donc le film
pouvait sortir et ça tombait avec tous
les débats sur le projet de loi 21 donc
c'était pas planifié mais en même temps
je me dis si ça peu moi mon but c'était
de retourner sur cette époque où il y
avait ce débat où sont ceux non débat
parce que malheureusement il n'y avait
pas vraiment des changes y avait surtout
les insultes entre les deux camps et je
me suis dit ce serait intéressant qu'on
retourne vers la la tête un peu plus
reposé pour pouvoir essayer de de voir
ce qui ne va pas dans ces débats de
société c'est des débats de société qui
sont importants l'ars la charte de la
laïcité c'est quelque chose de très
important mais quand même comment mener
ces débats sans qu'il y ait toute cette
virulence et 7
parfois cette mauvaise
aussi vous parler de deux refus de
dialogue des deux côtés quand vous
parlez des deux côtés donc aucune
représentation de religieuse dans
l'espace public à la liberté de porter
l'intégrer la liberté de porter l'un
saigne religieux qu'on veut porter
disque il ya effectivement eu une
fracture un non lieu un espace de deux
noms volonté pourquoi parce que parce
qu'on se met en danger kraton ça va dans
une zone là mais je crois qu'il ya des
gens il ya beaucoup de faiseurs
d'opinion qui le font par conviction
parce qu'ils censurent que accepter le
que les gens portent des signes
religieux dans la fonction publique qui
va va avoir une signification du retour
de la religion dans la société
québécoise
ce qui n'est pas vraiment le cas pour
beaucoup de gens je crois que ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que tout le monde
croit avoir raison et tout le monde a un
peu raison
et comme je disais dans le film chacun
aussi un peu tort donc si qu il ya des
gens qui veulent pas se remettre en
question parce qu'ils croient que ils
vont en vouloir ils vont laisser l'autre
avoir raison mais au fait
tout le monde a droit à sa façon de voir
qui est différente et ce qu'il faut
comprendre aussi c'est que je crois que
beaucoup d'immigrants ne comprennent pas
aussi l'histoire des québécois delà de
la l'aja volition que de la révolution
tranquille toute cette histoire n'est
pas très connue d'immigrants je crois
que ça c'est à faire connaître et en
même temps peut-être que le rejet de la
religion qui s'est faite au québec n'est
pas la même révolution qui se fait
ailleurs au québec avec la révolution
tranquille
il ya eu un rejet total de la religion
il y à d'autres sociétés qui sont encore
très très proches de leur religion et
peut-être que expliqué que la
sécularisation d'une société c'est
quelque chose de très important vous
pour aller vers la démocratie mais en
même temps c'est pas tout le monde qui
est prêt à en rejeter complètement sa
religion
donc c'est ce
lors de débats constructifs qui a pas
encore au québec et est encore ailleurs
également a passé seulement la pologne
notamment avec la religion catholique
exacte et même dans les pays musulmans
je viens de finir un film qui s'appelle
islam de mon enfance qui est un but sur
l'impact on a parlé d'ailleurs voilà sur
l'impact de de l'intégrisme sur les
mentalités dans mon pays d'origine qui
est l'algérie est dans pont dans
beaucoup de pays musulmans
quand on parle de laïcité c'est
complètement s'est tout de suite c'est
la critique de la religion au clc
l'athéisme et tout ça et donc c'est
important de com et puis quand on
regarde un peu l'historique de tous les
pays qui sont laïques ou séculaire même
en occident en europe par exemple la
laïcité en france n'est pas la laïcité
en espagne ou en allemagne
pas du tout donc c'est très différent et
encore des pays qui sont un peu plus
religieux mais séculaire et donc au
québec on veut souvent aller vers la
laïcité à la française alors qu'on n'a
pas aussi l histoire de la france donc
et on n'a pas la même immigration que la
france aussi on a une immigration qui
éduque et qu'on choisit qui est donc je
crois que c'est c'est des détails qui
font que ce que le québec va devenir
avec son projet de laïcité va être
différent de la france de l'allemagne et
d'autres pays maintenant comment ramener
ces débats d'une façon plus constructif
sans aller vers la virulence la
diffamation la division de la société et
c'est un peu pour ça que je fais ce film
parce que c'est sûr que initialement
j'aurais aimé que les gens qui étaient
contre
pour le projet de charte me parle aussi
ces gens là que l'avocate anne-france
goldwater qui représentait et dalila
mené en cours j'aurais voulu aussi qu'il
participe parce que mon but c'est
vraiment de pouvoir faire asseoir tout
le monde est de parler
malheureusement
ils n'ont pas accepté et donc c'est sûr
que le film dénonce il raconte un peu
commun un cauchemar la diffamation parce
que c'est affreux
mais cette jeune fille a vécu ce que
beaucoup de jeunes femmes vivent des
deux camps ont fait mais il y en avait
pas beaucoup qui pouvait parler et j'ai
même approché d'autres jeunes qui sont
un peu dans les médias qui sont dans le
déni migrants qui sans qui essaye
d'arriver dans les médias dans le module
de l'humour du rire et tout mais les
gens ont très très peur
dalila était déjà dans un processus de
d'aller en cours donc son cas était
publique elle a accepté de parler mais à
beaucoup de femmes qui disparaissent
carrément du monde médiatique qui
veulent pas par les médias pourquoi
kafka pourquoi le procès le procès de
kafka parce qu'au fait quand je
cherchais ma fille a un titre pour le
film au début je voulais l'appeler
dalila jeannette et dalila parce que
c'est un peu les jeannettes et les
dalits là c'est les deux finalistes
fortement été beau show biz toutes les
deux ans jeanne bertin et de dire
exactement dans le procès kafka dans son
procès il parle un peu de l'absurde de
nos débats de société et donc je crois
que soixante dix ans après on en est là
encore mais c'est le procès 2.0 parce
que c'est un peu monsieur madame tout le
monde qui sont derrière leurs claviers
dans l'intimité de leur maison qui se
permettent la virulence et incroyable de
dire n'importe quoi alors qu'à l'époque
c'était pas possible en pop on peut pas
aller dans le balkan ouvrir le bal quand
écrié maintenance et n'importe qui peut
écrire et je crois que c'est un film de
réflexion vraiment parce que quand même
des lilas à gagner et peut-être que anne
france goldwater a marqué un point où on
commence maintenant à vouloir légiférer
sur ça donc les gens font plus attention
d'ailleurs même quand je faisais la
recherche
quant à l' france goldwater a décidé de
dédier des lilas aller en cours contre
ces gens là il y avait beaucoup de
propos qui ont été effacées et tout ça
parce que les gens avaient peur et donc
je me dis si ça peut servir à cela c'est
c'est très bien et sa mise en garde sur
facebook elle même est à voir et à lire
est envoyé bien de choses incroyables
qui a dit aussi quand elle dit ce que je
veux voir de ce québec qui est le nôtre
où je vis où je sus société dans
laquelle je fait totalement partie je
suis né ici c'est de voir une musulmane
juive s'embrasser se dire bonjour
s'échanger des robes ou peut-être ou
peut-être même des hidjabs c'était lent
mais aussi quand serge bouchard lesage
monsieur serge bouchard quand il sait sa
référence à la sagesse amérindienne
prendre le bar le bâton de parole vient
avec une responsabilité de fond et c'est
peut-être vers ça qu'il faudrait aller
d'être à cette avant garde de cette
discussion mais comme vous il ya trop de
gens qui ne veulent pas y aller ou
parfois c'est des gens qui enregistre
peur hein parce qu'ils croient que en
acceptant ça il va y avoir des religieux
un peu partout mais c'est pas le cas je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
peur à la population
mais je crois qu'il est très important
d'avoir des gens comme serge bouchard
comme anne france goldwater des gens qui
vont dire non c'est pas ça le québec est
un état un véritable laboratoire du
vivre ensemble
on est en train de créer une société
dans la diversité en et 1 2% qui
essayant de survivre en amérique du nord
et c'est une très belle société parce
que à force de parler division on oublie
de parler de ce qui nous réunit qui est
beaucoup plus important que ce qui est
née d'une ce qui nous divise et je crois
que c'est important d'essayer de
construire là dessus et puis on est
aussi un exemple pour le reste du monde
parce que je vois par exemple dans mon
pays d'origine dans le film que je viens
de faire je parle de la dessiner noir et
coûtait 99 % des algériens sont
musulmans pourtant ils ont ils ont
trouvé le moyen de s'entretuer à cause
d'une religion qui est la même religion
pour tout le monde donc c'est un peu le
danger de d'instrumentaliser les
religions les problèmes ethniques les
divisions ethniques et je crois qu'au
québec on vient d'un peu partout on
arrive à vivre ensemble on a une langue
qui nous unit on a on a une charte des
valeurs
qui nous unit et c'est un exemple pour
le reste du monde et je me dis c'est un
peu dommage c'est pour ça que ce film ne
l'est pas vraiment publiciser ailleurs
que au québec parce que je voulais pas
je voulais que ce soit entre nous un peu
je vais je voulais que ce soit un film
de réflexion pour le québec mais mais en
même temps c'est important de parler de
ces de ces exactions pour pouvoir nous
corriger parce que sinon on pourra
jamais regarder ce qui va pendant la
société madjo the way we
merci pour ce regard merci à vous